south carolina senator
lindsey graham
so senator you understand where we're
coming from here do you think that we
should have been plowing full steam
ahead to bring ukraine into nato was
that our
strategy here or what was the strategy
well i think you're misreading the tea
leaves with all due respect putin gave a
speech last year where he said that
ukraine was a fiction
if you don't believe putin wants to take
the ukraine and make it part of russia
you're not listening to what he said i
do
okay well moldova's next hitler did this
whole thing people didn't believe he had
the ambitions he had he wanted to take
over the world and kill all the jews
here's what putin wants to do he wants
to recreate the soviet union you think
is he thinks it was a low point in
russian history in 1994 jesse
the third largest nuclear nation on the
planet was ukraine they signed an
agreement with russia great britain uh
and the united states where they would
give up their nuclear weapons with a
promise by russia to guarantee their
sovereignty putin stepped all over that
like hitler did so
putin's the bad guy
biden's the incompetent guy
and i just want to say i agree with that
and you know it was bill clinton that
signed that deal to move those nuclear
weapons out of ukraine if they had had
nukes now this would have been a
different story but do you think that
american foreign policy should have been
a little bit more delicate with ukraine
maybe used a little more finesse and
tried to keep it more as a buffer
instead of just just wrenching it out of
putin's hands and just bringing it right
into nato as aggressively as possible
would that have changed things because
now
americans are suffering ukraine is
definitely suffering and who knows where
the hell this could go
they had the same arguments about hitler
why don't we just give him the
german-speaking portions
surrounding why don't we give him
austria
you've got to understand who putin is
putin's not trying to have a buffer zone
from nato he's trying to destroy the
ukraine and make it part of russia he's
trying to recreate the soviet union to
the best extent possible and taiwan is
going to be given up if we think like
this i'm not going to let putin control
nato nato is an independent organization
nobody in nato is going to invade russia
but if you don't believe that putin's
ambitions are to reconstruct the
greater russia or the soviet union
you're missing what he said i do i agree
and i think that's what his motivation
is i'm just saying maybe that aggressive
approach to ukraine might have made
things a little differently i could be
wrong i could be wrong listen i really
like your show because you let people
talk number one you ask good questions
here's why i think we made a mistake
we should have punched putin in the nose
when he had a hundred thousand troops on
the border of ukraine we should have
went after the oil and gas sector early
on to maybe deter the invasion at every
moment uh biden appeased putin and
here's what you have today you have good
people in the ukraine fighting to the
death for their freedom you have the
russian army stalled i think the the
chinese are watching how we deal with
putin saw the iranians so what happens
that the ukraine doesn't stay in the
ukraine
let's help the ukrainians fight back as
hard as they can
let's start destroying the rupal uh you
know why biden went after russian oil
and gas no change of heart change
changing politics americans are pissed
that we allowed putin to get so
reckless and so strong biden it makes
chamberlain look like churchill so
here's my view of this and i said it on
a show weeks ago when it comes to bully
stand up to him putin has a pair of twos
we have a full house i want him to go
i want him i want his regime to end i
hope people in russia will take the
bastard out if we've done this 20 years
ago we'd be a lot better off what have
we learned from history the longer you
let people
go who murder rape steal and plunder
you live to regret it so now is the time
to be all in to help the ukrainian
people fight for their own freedom no
boots on the ground but we can tie we
can turn the tide of battle and we got
to tell the russian people you will
never have a normal life if you follow
this guy putin we're going to destroy
the russian rupal the russian economy
and i'm hoping somebody in russia will
step up to the plate and do what they
should have done in germany i gotta get
your answer on this senator the
the the polls sending uh migs to us and
germany it seems like they're forcing
our hand a little bit what do you think
about that and also are you for a no-fly
zone
i'm not for a no-fly zone you know one
of the things you've been talking about
world war iii is not going to happen
because it's engagement but what could
happen is that china could take taiwan
and iran could see our weakness and try
to get a nuclear weapon that could start
a nuclear arms race in the mideast i'm
all for the migs going from germany back
into the ukraine let the ukrainian
pilots come to germany flying back into
the ukraine and take the fight to the
russians this is a defining moment in
european history it's defining moment in
american history putin can't determine
who's in nato and putin doesn't want to
stop nato he wants to reconstruct the
soviet union and the the russian
imperial life and we got a chance here
to deliver a fatal blow to putin the
best chance in 20 years and god bless
the ukrainian people for having the
gusts to fight for their freedom all
right we'll see how it plays out senator
lindsey graham thanks for joining us
thank you